good morning John this counters video
the thing is that there's nothing to say
don't know anything I think I'm gonna
have to come back tomorrow and make a
video then I was trying to remember that
the world is a good place and that the
number of hugs per gunshot victim is
very very high lots of hugs per gunshot
I was gonna make a video today about um
having friends who have ulcerative
colitis and how to treat them as I just
made a video on Hanks channel about me
having ulcerative colitis I do which is
a very personal video but now I don't
feel like talking about anything as far
as like analysis or musings or anything
like I got nothing I think everybody
feels about the same but is a good time
to feel like we're together as humanity
and as the project for awesome is coming
up that's nice that we're all ready to
work together to make the world suck
less and we can do that you know we can
make the world better we can do it in
little ways we can do it in big ways and
so if you want to participate in that
project for awesome will be sort of the
centralized place we'll also be having
the livestream on the vlogbrothers
channel and you want to go there now and
sign of the mailing list if you haven't
already make sure if you've signed up
for previous year's mailing list that
doesn't count
so go sign up for the mailing list and
that's how we will be coordinating so
you need to be signed up for that
everybody who has the ability to should
make a video promoting charities that
they care the most about together on
Monday word just gonna take over YouTube
for good stuff feel good about doing
good things together because we do
humanity is good some people are
terrible and broken but humanity is good
I believe that I think probably I'll be
able to make a real video tomorrow so
everybody you'll see me tomorrow